obwohl schönheit als auch intelligenz
sind zu groß und teil genetisch bedingt
freude der sonne letzte woche habe ich
erwähnt dass intelligenz genetisch
bedingt ist so groß und teil und ihr
habt gesagt moment mal freundchen der
sonne intelligenz genetisch heißt das
nicht denn auch dass die intelligenz
verschiedener bevölkerungsgruppen oder
ethnien genetisch bedingt ist wobei wir
doch alle wissen dass asiaten sowieso
die chancen sind dieses thema geht
natürlich nicht nur wissenschaftlich
diskutiert sondern vor allem auch
politisch und dabei werden
wissenschaftliche ergebnisse immer
wieder missverstanden und zwar auf allen
seien deswegen ist dieses thema
erblichkeit und intelligenz das perfekte
beispiel um eine ganz wichtige lektion
zu lernen nämlich in der wissenschaft
geht es nicht nur um die ergebnisse
sondern auch um die methodik methodik
heißt auf welche art und weise bin ich
überhaupt zu den ergebnissen gekommen
und ich verspreche euch wenn ihr die
methodik hinter diesem thema am ende
dieses videos erstmal kennt dann ist die
antwort auf die frage bestimmt meine
herkunft meine intelligenz eigentlich
ganz einfach
[Musik]
holt euch nt freunde der sonne oder ein
heiß oder kaltgetränk eurer wahl macht
es euch gemütlich wir nehmen uns mal
wieder ein bisschen zeit wie seien seien
es erst mal wovon sprechen wir
eigentlich wenn wir von intelligenz
sprechen hier sprechen wir immer vom
intelligenzquotienten also professionell
durchgeführte iq tests sind auch unter
experten anerkannte tools um die
intelligenz zu messen
trotzdem kann man sich natürlich fragen
ist der iq überhaupt repräsentativ für
die intelligenz und kann so eine zahl
überhaupt so viel aussagen ist sicher
eine diskussion wert in einem anderen
video vielleicht so viel tee hab ich
jetzt heute auch wieder nicht so dann
schauen wir doch mal was eigentlich so
heikel an diesem thema ist 2010 sorgte
thilo sarrazin für aufruhr weil er
unter anderem behauptete intelligenz sei
zu 50 bis 80 prozent erblich bedingt da
seien sich wissenschaft einig und daraus
leitete er eine argumentation haben die
schon viel älter ist als 2010 bereits im
neunzehnten jahrhundert beklagte francis
gärten übrigens ein cousin von charles
darwin in seinem buch genie und
verehrung dass sich höhere klassen
weniger fortpflanzen als ich sag mal der
arme pöbel was zu einer verschlechterung
der rasse führe
naja klingt erschreckend bekannt oder
diese theorie genannt roy genick wurde
später unter anderem von den nazis
aufgegriffen um ihre kranke idee einer
herrenrasse auf besonders grausame art
und weise in die tat umzusetzen dass das
jetzt alles eine kranke scheiße war es
klar aber zurück bleibt immer noch die
frage ist intelligent jetzt genetisch
bedingt die antwort ist ja
aber aber aber aber aber aber es gibt
fünf missverständnisse die mit diesem
jahr zusammenhängen missverständnis
nummer 1 es gibt einen intelligenz gehen
nein was man weiß
intelligenz hängt mit einer vielzahl von
genen oder gehen variationen zusammen
was man nicht weiß welche das genau sind
unerträglich wie die auch noch
miteinander wechselwirken
missverständnis nummer 29 iq ist zu
sechs prozent genetisch bedingt
nein aber die antwort ist ja
nein also was jetzt intelligenz geht auf
gene und auf umwelt zurück das ist
unumstritten auch besteht heutzutage
unter fans genetiker der konsens darüber
dass der erbliche anteil durchaus
wesentlich ist aber alle zahlen die ihr
in diesem zusammenhang hört oder liest
50 prozent 60 prozent 80 prozent was
weiß ich
die beziehen sich nicht auf den
ehrlichen anteil der intelligenz an sich
sondern nur auf den unterschied von
intelligenten innerhalb einer gruppe von
menschen wenn man diese miteinander
vergleicht beispiel nehmen wir ein paar
ein eigenes
diese beiden eineiigen zwillinge kam zu
100 dieselbe dna wie das leben so ist
bei allen eigen zwillinge
diese beiden zwillinge haben aber nicht
denselben iq gleiche dna
unterschiedlicher iq
daraus kann man ableiten der unterschied
ist zu 100% umwelt bedingt um zu null
prozent genetisch bedingt richtig ich
dich daraus kann man aber nicht ableiten
die intelligenz dieser zwillinge ist zu
null prozent genetisch bedingt nein die
intelligenz dieser zwillinge hat
sicherlich auch irgend einen
signifikanten genetischen anteil wie
können nur darüber keine aussage treffen
ich bitte euch merkt euch dieses
beispiel von gerade und ich werde im
laufe des videos auch immer wieder
darauf hinweisen und zwar mit hilfe
dieses eis wenn ihr diese seht dann
erinnert euch daran was wir gerade
gelernt haben nämlich wir können nur
ableiten zu welchem prozentsatz
intelligenz unterschiede genetisch
bedingt sind wir können nicht ableiten
zu welchem prozentsatz intelligenz an
sich genetisch bedingt ist never forget
sehr wichtige sache denn in der praxis
in der wissenschaftlichen praxis schaut
man sich immer nur intelligenz
unterschiede an die unterschiede lassen
sich mathematisch durch die sogenannte
varianz ausdrücken die varianz
beschreibt das ausmaß der unterschiede
beziehungsweise das ausmaß der streuung
je unterschiedlicher die akkus innerhalb
einer testgruppe desto größer die
varianz die varianz der intelligenz hat
einen genetischen anteil und ein umwelt
anteilen und einen fehler anteil keine
messung ohne fehler
so nennen die jetzt zahlen hören wie zum
beispiel intelligenz ist 50 prozent
erblich bedingt dann ist mir diesen 50
prozent die varianz gemeint 50 prozent
als nicht dass sich mein iq zur hälfte
aus jenen und zur hälfte aus umwelt
zusammensetzt genauso wie die
intelligenz in unserem zwillings
beispiel eben nicht zu null prozent
genetisch ist deshalb ist die varianz
auch immer abhängig von der testgruppe
werdet also in
messung immer eine andere varianz
rausbekommen je nachdem wie ihr eure
testgruppe auswählt fazit man kann keine
allgemeingültige erblichkeit von
intelligenz wissenschaftlich so
methodisch korrekt vermittelt
ok wenn das so ist woher kommen dann
überhaupt solche zahlen wie 50 prozent
oder 60 prozent klar die es erlaubt mir
einen kleinen schrieb zurück das ganze
genome also dass das ganze eher gut
unsere ganze dna ist von mensch zu
mensch nur minimal verschieden aber
dasselbe gehen also dieselbe sequenz
kann von mensch zu mensch in
verschiedenen variationen auftreten und
diese variationen nennt man allele
eineiige zwillinge teilen 100 prozent
ihrer allele also all ihrer genvarianten
normale geschwister teil nur 50 prozent
ihrer läden genauso eltern und kinder
teilen 50 prozent ihrer alte und das
nennt man eben auch den genetischen
verwandtschaftsgrad wenn man jetzt zwei
testgruppen mit bekannten aber
unterschiedlichen verwandtschaftsgrad
miteinander vergleicht kann man eine
schätzung abgeben über die allgemeine
ehrlichkeit dazu gibt es zwei klassische
ansätze erstens die zwillings methode
und zweitens die adoptions methode die
trainingsmethode schauen wir uns jetzt
hier als beispiel einmal genauer schön
dass ihr da seid herzlich willkommen bei
der zwillings methode dem studiendesign
bei dem mann eine gruppe von eineiigen
zwillingen mit einer gruppe von zwei
eigens villingen vergleicht der vorteil
der genetische unterschied zwischen
diesen beiden gruppen ist bekannt die
eineiigen zwillinge haben 100 prozent
genetische verwandtschaft die zweieiigen
zwillinge 50 prozent weiterer vorteil
die umwelt unterschiede also die umwelt
variant sind zwar an sich nicht bekannt
man kann aber davon ausgehen dass die
umwelt unterschiede für diese beiden
gruppen jeweils gleich große wenn die
umwelt unterschiede gleichen folgt
daraus wenn die eineiigen zwillinge sich
ähnlicher sind im iq dann nur weil sie
sich genetisch ähnlicher sind richtig
so wie bekommt man jetzt hier aber
zahlen raus stellt euch vor jedes
zwillingspaaren daten per wir müssen von
jedem paar den iq und tragen das
ergebnis in ein koordinatensystem ein iq
von zu legen um 1 gegen iq von zwilling
nummer zwei denn jedes zwillingspaar
genau denselben die kuh hat dann liegen
alle daten punkte genau auf dieser linie
wenn er ein zwillingspaar
unterschiedliche akkus hat zum beispiel
der eine hat 105 und anderer 95 dann
liegt der punkt 105 95 nicht auf der
linie und ihr unterschiedlicher die
akkus desto weiter ist der daten punkt
von der linie entfernt einen zahlen maß
dafür ist der sogenannte korrelation sco
effizienz eine korrelation sco effizient
von 1 beschreibt den extremfall dass
alle daten punkte genau auf der linie
liegen das würde heißen alle
zwillingspaare haben genau demselben iq
eine korrelation sco effizient von 0
beschreibt den extremfall das ist gar
keine korrelation zuschnitts villingen
gibt das würde heißen der iq des ein
zwillings hat gar nichts mit dem eco des
anderen zu tun
je näher der korrelation effizient also
an eins dran liegt der gemessene der
mitte desto ähnlicher sind sich die
zwillinge im iq wenn man jetzt ein idol
und zweieiige zwillinge vergleicht
findet man eigentlich immer dasselbe
ergebnis nämlich die ein eigen sind sich
in die kuh ähnlicher als die zwei eigene
zum beispiel haben die einen eigenen
heim korrelation effizienten von 0,86
die zwei eigenen nur von 0,6 die
differenz der korrelation effizienten
ist also 0,26 oder auch 26 prozent weil
sich jetzt eine eigene zwillinge 100
prozent ihrer alle teilen und zweieiige
nur 50 prozent schätzt man diese 26
prozent also diese differenz als die
hälfte der genetischen varianz der
geschätzte genetischen varianz anteil
gibt sich also zu 26% mal zwei sind 52
prozent und das freunde der sonne war
die methode mit der man auf konkrete
zahl wie zum beispiel 52 prozent kommt
darüber hinaus benutzt man auch oft die
adoptions methode hier vergleicht man
bleib wichtige geschwister mit adoptiv
geschwister gehe ich jetzt nicht im
detail darauf ein
die frage ist doch warum benutzt wenn
überhaupt verschiedene methoden das
macht man in der wissenschaft eigentlich
so gut es geht immer um zu vermeiden
dass man keine systematischen fehler
macht die mit einer ganz bestimmten
methode zusammenhängen zum beispiel die
die genetische varianten zwillings
methoden systematisch überschätzt und in
adoptions methoden systematisch
unterschätzt
und wenn man jetzt so durch die
literatur durchgeht dann finden
eigentlich alle experten irgend einen
signifikanten anteil an genetischer
varianz aber die zahl ist immer eine
andere jena studiendesign irgendwas 30
und 80 prozent warum ist das so heißt
das jetzt diese schätzungen sind
schlecht und hier kommen wir zu
missverständnis nummer drei
wissenschaftlich ermittelte zahlen
repräsentieren eine allgemeingültige
realität nein nein nein das spiel
zwillings methode zwillinge sind ja
offensichtlich sehr spezielle
testpersonen die meisten menschen auf
dieser welt sind keine zwillinge
weswegen man allgemeingültige aussagen
nur schätzen aber gerade weil man
zwillinge nimmt hat man sich damit so
einen speziellen rahmen und so spezielle
testbedingungen dass man systematischen
untersuchungen überhaupt erst
durchführen kann besteht ihr das ist die
grund ist jetzt von forschung die viele
missverstehen nämlich jede methode ist
systematisch und gleichzeitig auch
begrenzt der wissenschaft geht es
überhaupt nicht um fakten fakten fakten
eigentlich geht es tatsächlich nur um
pelzigs contex kontext hab ich da gerade
kontext gehört und da seid ihr ja schon
wieder herzlich willkommen beim
diskussions teil der zwillings methode
erstens wieder hoch weil dieselbe
zwilling studie mit älteren zwillingen
zu kommen um eine größere genetische
variante warum und hat
interessanterweise festgestellt dass
eineiige zwillinge im laufe ihres lebens
immer etwa gleich bleiben also auch
gleich intelligent
während zweieiige zwillinge mit dem
alter sich immer stärker unterscheiden
wirklich ganz spannende beobachtung
darüber
könnte man sicherlich auch noch länger
diskutieren was daraus folgt ist
jedenfalls dass bei älteren zweieiigen
zwillingen der korrelation effizient
kleider ist weil sie sich mehr
unterscheiden und dadurch wird die
differenz zwischen den 1 und 2 großer
und damit eben auch der genetische
varianten teil 2 1 2 1 gegen teilen sich
zwar 50 prozent ihrer allele also ihre
genvariationen das heißt aber nicht
unbedingt dass sie sich auch genau 50
prozent ihrer intelligenz g note
intelligenz alle teile zumal wir ja gar
nicht wissen welche gehen variationen
nun tatsächlich für die intelligenz
zuständig ist drittens wir machen bei
der zwillings methode die annahme dass
die umweltfaktoren für die 1 und 2 eigen
gleich groß sind ist das eine gute
annahme oder ist sie zu einfach ist es
nicht vielleicht doch so dass eineiige
zwillinge ihre umwelt anders wahrnehmen
oder ihre umwelt anders auf sie reagiert
als es bei zwei eigenen der fall ist
jedenfalls ich hoffe ihr seht das
ergebnis allein und selbst wenn es eine
zahl ist sagt uns erstmal noch nicht so
viel solange wir nicht das ganze
außenrum kennen celtics contex kontext
versteht das bloß nicht falsch damit
möchte ich nichts sagen dass das
schlechte wissenschaft ist im gegenteil
gute wissenschaft heißt contex geben
dazu gehört dass man weiß was die stärke
der befunde sind aber auch dass man weiß
was die schwächen der methode sind und
wo die grenzen sind das heißt all das
ist überhaupt nicht meine persönliche
krieg oder mein persönliches review all
diese abwägung werden euch die forscher
selbst schwarz auf weiß liefern das
gehört nämlich in jede ordentliche
wissenschaftliche veröffentlichung und
findet sich unter dem abschluss
discussion
seit auch da gut missverständnis nummer
vier genetische faktoren und
umweltfaktoren sind unabhängig
voneinander nein nein überhaupt nicht
unser genom also unser erbgut und unsere
umwelt korrelieren
das heißt je größer die genetischen
einflüsse desto größer auch die
umwelteinflüsse und andersrum
es gibt drei bekannte genio umwelt
korrelation erstens eine aktive genom
umwelt korrelation jetzt ziemlich
verrückt aber irgendwie auch logisch die
gene suchen sich gewissermaßen aktiv die
umwelt zu der sie aufpassen sagen wir
ein kind ist musikalisch veranlagt
genäht stand wird sich dieses kind
vielleicht für das erlernen eines
musikinstruments interessieren es wird
vielleicht öfter auf konzerte gehen oder
auch mehr musik hören was wiederum seine
musikalität von außen durch die umwelt
fördert zweitens die reaktive gehen um
umwelt korrelation die umwelt reagiert
gewissermaßen auch auf unsere
genetischen veranlagung nehmen wir
wieder unser musikalisches kind das
sitzt im musikunterricht und der
musiklehrerin der schule dem feld das
auf und er steckt das kind ins orchester
wo es dann wiederum musikalisch
gefördert wird durch die umwelt drittens
die passive gehen um umwelt korrelation
sagen wir zwei eltern sind musikalisch
sie haben sich im orchester
kennengelernt und sie zeugen ein kind
das ebenfalls eine genetische
veranlagung zur musikalität hat jetzt
kommt noch hinzu dass dieses kind hier
auch in einem haushalt aufwächst wo es
von musikinstrumenten umgeben ist oder
wo ich jeden tag musik gemacht wird was
wiederum die musikalität förder zweitens
epigenetik unsere gene bestimmen wenn
man so will erstmal noch gar nicht und
so eigenschaften weil sie an sich gar
nicht aktiv sind unsere gene haben zwar
unsere information in sich codiert aber
diese information muss erst mal gelesen
und übersetzt werden
so will in proteine oder enzyme ob jetzt
eingehend eine aktive funktion hat oder
nicht hat einerseits mit der sequenz und
variationen den alleen zu tun
andererseits können aber tatsächlich
auch äußere einflüsse die aktivierung
überhaupt erst triggern schönes beispiel
hatten wir bei unserer klimawandel
therapie des geschlechtes schildkröten
babys wird maßgeblich von der temperatur
während der brutzeit bestimmt an warmen
stränden schlüpfen meerweibchen an
kälteren stränden schlüpften mehr milch
ist geschlechtes schildkröte wird
natürlich genetisch bestimmt aber eben
auch epigenetisch nehme ich eben auch
durch die temperatur unter strich heißt
das gene und umwelt lassen sich nicht
trennen
das ist ganz wichtig denn diese
klassischen methoden die klassischen
zwillings und applikations methoden tun
genau das sie trennen die genetischen
faktoren die umweltfaktoren weil man
sonst gar nicht systematischen
untersuchungen anstellen kann und genau
deswegen arbeiten verhaltens genetiker
derzeit an neuen optimierten methoden
die diese korrelation auch irgendwie mit
einrechnen köln geht es eigentlich nur
wenn man versucht aus aus aus diesen
wissenschaftlichen ergebnissen
gesellschaftliche konsequenzen zu ziehen
und ich will natürlich nicht leugnen
dass auch wissenschaftler menschen sind
und menschen mit politischen oder
ideologischen überzeugungen und deswegen
gab es in der vergangenheit auch immer
wieder wissenschaftler die trotz all dem
was ich euch jetzt die ganze erklärt
habe extreme gesellschaftliche
konsequenzen forderten sei es gelten der
die nazis die basis für ihre kranke
ideologie lieferte oder auch john watson
der am anderen ende des spektrums
behauptete alle persönlichen
eigenschaften seien reine
konditionierung von außen und gespielten
gar keine rolle
in diesem gesellschaftlichen kontext ist
das letzte missverständnis wohl das
wichtigste missverständnis fünf manche
bevölkerungsgruppen sind genetisch
bedingt intelligenter als andere
nein nach all dem was wir heute gelernt
haben ist dass sei methodisch gar nicht
nachweisbar in allen wissenschaftlichen
studien sagen wie gesagt nichts über
individuelle intelligenzen ausländern
über den unterschied innerhalb einer
testgruppe aus dem habe ich gerade unter
punkt 4 auf nur einen winzigen teil der
vielen beispiele aufgezählt wie umwelt
und genom zusammenhängen und stark
miteinander verstrickt sind wenn wir
jetzt verschiedene länder vergleichen
wollen können ja allein
kulturunterschiede schon so groß sein
und kultur ist natürlich ein
wesentlicher teil der umwelt dasselbe
gilt natürlich nicht nur für kultur
sondern zum beispiel auch für den
sozioökonomischen status fassen wir
zusammen erstens intelligenz ist auch
sehr viele gene oder gehen variationen
zurückzuführen wir wissen nur nicht
genau auf welche zwei intelligenz
unterschiede unterschiede sind zu großen
teil genetisch bedingt wobei
umweltfaktoren und genetische faktoren
auch miteinander korrelieren drittens
niemand ist opfer seiner gene oder opfer
seiner umwelt man wird nicht einfach
intelligent geboren und das war es und
man kann auch nicht durch meine
erziehung bildung und so weiter
intelligent werden es ist viel
komplizierter ist das was auch die länge
dieses videos zeigt die wäre diesmal hat
er keine kekse modus verteilen an alle
die das video bis hierhin gesehen haben
trixi motivs werden wir an anderer
stelle definitiv noch mal verteilen
unter anderen bedingungen aber wenn ihr
das video bisschen gesehen habt dann
lass mir doch ein kinoshita weil dann
kann ich das sehen und mich freuen
wir sehen uns nächsten donnerstag bis
dahin plötzlich er
[Musik]